hey you guys time once again for
flickers of fear
this movie that we're talking about
today is one that i've actually been
wanting to revisit for a really long
time i think i even put it in a few of
our
patreon polls like to do the movie
retrospective on that me and tom would
do because i remember seeing it a long
time ago and it making something of an
impression but i hadn't seen it since
then i probably only saw it one time but
i had been wanting to
see it again ever since i was scrolling
through to be like a few months ago and
saw that it was available on there for
free
and
it's interesting because i kind of feel
like
this is generally billed as a black
comedy which i guess it kind of is and i
think that i always had that impression
of it that it was kind of like a dark
comedy and a lot of that may be
attributable to the cover art which
makes it look like very funny and like
very satirical so i guess i had
forgotten that
this movie while technically i guess it
is a black comedy it's not
exactly like what you might be imagining
it's very it's actually more a straight
horror movie and more like a surreal
kind of experience so actually i was
really happy that i watched it again
because i was kind of thinking i don't
know why i remembered it like that like
i just remembered it was like some kind
of goofy i might have been like mixing
it up with another similar type of movie
from the time i'm not really sure
but i just i don't know i remember it
being like much funnier but this one is
actually
funny but the the sense of humor in it
is very very
dry it's not kind of like uh like oh
that was hilarious type of thing it's a
much more unsettling
uh type of vibe to it and at the toward
the end of it it goes like into pretty
much a straight-on horror film uh so
it's a really interesting
sort of cultural relic and it's one it's
another one that i feel like doesn't
really get talked about all that much um
i think it has kind of a small cult
following
but
not as big a cult following as i feel
like it probably deserves because this
is a [ __ ] weird ass movie and i had
forgotten how weird it was so it made me
like appreciate i'm just like oh that's
awesome that it was like way weirder
than i remembered so this is parents
from 1989
now i wasn't aware of this when i first
watched it but this was directed by bob
balaban now if you don't know that name
uh he's i guess he's mostly known as an
actor and he's been in [ __ ]
everything i was like i think he's best
known for being in like christopher
guest films he was in a bunch of wes
anderson movies um he was in midnight
cowboy actually uh he had a small part
in that
which tom and i just reviewed a couple
days ago he was in close encounters he
was in altered states he was in all kind
of like he's in everything i said and
even like recently when i rewatched um i
am the pretty thing that lives in the
house from i think that's 2016 that came
out uh he had a small part in that as
well actually he's been in a bunch of
movies but he's also been at a bunch of
like tv shows as well like he was on
seinfeld and all this other kind of
stuff so
i wasn't aware but he's also a
children's book author and he's a
director now this is his first feature
film i believe he only did maybe three
movies and i think that the critical and
audience response to this first film and
the fact that it didn't make any money
probably didn't really endear him to
you know filmmaking executives or
producers or whatever
but he did actually direct a really lot
of tv episodes like he did the pilot he
directed the pilot episode for tales
from the dark side um he did some
episodes of eerie indiana if you guys
remember that show from the 90s um he
did a couple i think he did one episode
of strangers with candy if you guys
remember that one so the dude is just
like super super multi-talented like i
said even if you don't know his name you
would immediately recognize his face
because he's just a very prolific
character actor and also a director so
he directed this movie
and i see it gets a lot of comparisons
with
david lynch which i can see that it's
really strange because even though this
came out in 1989 which was around the
same time that twin peaks the tv show
was also in production i kind of feel
like the vibe of this movie is very much
like twin peaks but it's not but it
didn't come out like it came out or it
was being made around the same time so
it's not necessarily like he was like
ripping it off although
i've seen like some comparisons to
blue velvet as well
even though it's i get that it's like a
slightly different tone to that this is
more twin peaksy to me than blue velvety
but i get like how people are saying
that watching it again yesterday like
for this review
the movie that it most reminded me of
oddly was society which also came out in
1989 the brian ysna film
and uh i kind of feel like it's i don't
know it's kind of different this i
honestly i think society
even though these movies they're not
they're not thematically similar but
just i don't know like the tone of it is
very very similar to me this one is not
as
grotesque or like over the top and it
has like much more of a weird like david
lynch meets john waters kind of vibe to
it which
you don't really see a lot of this it's
really really hard to explain like what
kind of movie this is like i said i
think that's why it usually just gets
lumped into black comedy horror
and it is but it's not super over the
top funny you know what i'm saying like
the sense of humor is just like really
it's a very disquieting film uh
interestingly so as i said this came out
in 1989 and basically what you have
is it set in 1958 in this kind of father
knows best you know very very idealized
1950s americana i will say too like
before i even get into it the production
design in this is amazing i really
really love
um just the way the insides of the
houses look and just like it looks
spot-on it looks like the 1950s you know
what i mean it looks like you went back
in time and like are hanging out in
people's houses it's just a very very
1950s kind of vibe to the whole thing
it's really really well done they also
use like a lot of kind of cheesy
songs from the 50s like purple people
eater and you know there's some like
some uh some kind of mambo type of music
that kind of stuff so it has that real
kind of like kitschy
john waters vibe but then there's
something like really sinister like uh
underlying it which i think is like
really well done so yeah set in 1958 so
there's this family the lemley family
which is dad who's played by randy quaid
mom who's played by mary beth hurt and
uh michael their ten-year-old son who's
played by an actor this was his only
movie i think i don't know i don't know
if this was such a bad experience or he
just didn't want to be an actor or
something like that but yeah i'm pretty
sure this was the only movie that he was
ever in
so they moved to uh california from
massachusetts
now right from the jump
it's the the little boy michael comes
across he doesn't really have a lot of
lines he's a very
somber uh you can tell that he's very
very troubled like he kind of and he you
almost get the impression that he's like
afraid of something like he seems very
awkward he's kind of small for his age
there's all this other kind of stuff
and then you know there's a scene of him
at school where he has to stand up
because he's new and it's like well tell
us something that you're you're a new
student so like tell us something that
we don't know like tell us some new
information
and he comes up with this thing about
i guess it was something that he read in
a witchcraft book or something that if
like that if you kill and skin
what was it a black cat and like put it
in the oven and then eat the bones like
then you'll become invisible like he
just comes up with some [ __ ] like that
and everyone's just kind of like what so
he's a little bit of a weird kid
now it so happens that there's another
new student uh in the classroom with him
and it's this girl named i think her
name is sheila and she's a little bit
older she's like way taller because she
said she got held back a year and she's
also she's kind of intrigued by his
weirdness because she's also a little
bit weird because she was like oh
where'd you find that stuff out about
the cat and he's like oh i read it in
the library and then she uh
she basically tells him that she's from
the moon and comes up with all this kind
of stuff like she lived in a village on
the moon where it was all earth people
and stuff so these two weirdos are like
kind of hanging out together
now uh at home at michael's home
you have they're very very very [ __ ]
weird ass parents particularly randy
quaid playing the dad and it's like it's
a shame because randy quaid you know
very famously kind of went off the rails
like
in real life like later on he's like
basically a nut case
but he is actually great in this i think
this is i haven't seen obviously i
haven't seen like his entire filmography
or anything but
he is really really great in this
because he comes across as
your sort of aw shucks 50s dad type of
thing but he's also really super creepy
uh he just has this really sinister
kind of you know undertone going on with
his performance that's really really
well done and i think like the way that
it's shot too because sometimes there'll
be these very like i said very david
lynchy and kind of like close-ups that
are just like slightly too close and
then he's kind of sweaty and then like
he'll kind of like smile like a little
too wide and it's just kind of like this
really creepy kind of [ __ ]
now uh the dad his name is nick actually
and uh he works at i love this this is
one of my favorite things about the
movie he works at this chemical plant
and it's called toxico
and basically they're making he's
working on making essentially agent
orange it's like a defoliant and he's
they're talking about how awesome
chemicals are and uh you know we're
gonna just defoliate we'll just fly this
plane over this village in the rain
forest so we're just gonna like wipe
everything out you know what i mean like
all the trees of the people and
everything and they're just like talking
about how awesome this is toxico
uh for some reason
also has an in-house morgue you know as
one does
and uh i guess and they even have like a
door that says you know department of
human testing or whatever so i guess
they're like testing on humans
and it's not even like
no one even says anything about it
they're just like well that's just
that's what you do you know what i mean
so like i said this has a very satirical
kind of edge to it but it's not like in
your face with it it's very subtle i
mean i don't know if i'd say it was
subtle but you know because having a
science saying department of human
testing but they don't it's not like oh
look satire like look how funny it is
it's kind of like a satire of you know
this kind of like 1950s like i said this
father knows best idealized you know
this really repressed
you know conservative type of thing that
was going on in the 50s so it is like a
satire of that but i would call it like
i said i don't know if i'd call it
necessarily subtle but it's more like a
gentle satire they're not like making
you know they're not like putting
[ __ ] a clown nose on it you know what
i'm saying it's just kind of like they
don't explain necessarily why there's a
bunch of cadavers in this place and you
know when he just kind of goes in there
and cuts them up it's like yeah i want
some of the liver can you want me to
puree that sure yeah that'd be good you
know what i mean it's like because
they're gonna run all these tests on it
and it's just kind of treated like it's
just that's just what they do we're just
testing on all these cadavers
so uh so yeah dad does that
at his job and then mom uh is you know
obviously just like in the idealized
1950s sitcoms is a stay-at-home
mom and she's pretty much always like
cooking she's like super into cooking
now at this point like i said at the
beginning you're not entirely sure
because you know that michael the kid
is having some problems or he's like
afraid of something now at first you
think maybe it's just because he has all
these nightmares they kind of mentioned
that
you know that he's had nightmares before
and it's like a recurring thing and they
even show there's a lot of really great
like creepy cool like surreal
nightmare sequences in this that the kid
has like one like one of the best ones
that kind of goes along
almost like this little satirical john
watersy kind of thing and then all of a
sudden he's having a nightmare where he
jumps into bed and it just like turns
into this big ocean of blood so it's
just like this really cool like very
disconcerting type of imagery which i
think is really well done so he's been
having nightmares and um he doesn't
really want to
eat what his mom is always making for
dinner which is usually big huge
steaming plates of
meat and he's just kind of become
suspicious about where's this meat
coming from there's like a great
conversation in there where
you know since they've moved he's like
we've eaten leftovers like every night
since we moved and it's been like a week
or 10 days or whatever and he's like
what were these before they were
leftovers and his dad just kind of looks
at him and goes leftovers to be you know
what i mean so obviously they don't want
to tell him like where all this meat is
coming from
so for a long time i mean you know like
i said this movie came out in 1989 and
it's right there in the in the
description of the movie
the kid basically believes starts to
believe that his parents are cannibals
now
one of the things that gives him this
impression
uh and like i said they don't go into a
lot like what was going on like before
they moved or anything like that i mean
it does kind of come clear later on why
they had to move
but
you know other than the mom saying
something about him having like
nightmares previously and all this other
stuff it doesn't really go much into
like the backstory but there's one scene
where he gets up in the middle of the
night where michael gets up in the
middle of the night and he's going to
get like a glass of water and he sees
his parents having sex i guess like in
the like on the living room floor but
the way it's shot
you can't really tell what it is they're
doing and then like later on they show
it like the they re-contextualize it so
that maybe he saw something a lot more
graphic or a lot grosser like almost
like they were eating each other or they
were covered with blood or something
like that which they don't really show
at the beginning it's kind of more like
they have red smudges on their face but
it looks like lipstick maybe and they're
all kind of like sweaty and it's this
weird thing
so as the time goes on the kid seems to
become more and more convinced that
the meat that they're eating
is
from people you know what i mean is is
human meat
now
it's interesting because this movie for
a long time everything is kind of seen
from the subjective point of view of the
kid which i think is really good and
i've seen um i've seen one at least one
reviewer compare this movie to the
reflecting skin
which
it's a lot different than that it's not
quite as like arty
but it's still already but it's not it
doesn't have quite the same like vibe as
the reflecting skin but in the sense
that
everything is seen subjectively from a
child's point of view so you're not
entirely sure
you know and obviously he's really
troubled so you're not really sure if
he's seeing things
and not understanding them and then
casting them in as you know much like in
the reflecting skin where he thought
this woman was a vampire just because he
saw her do particular things and he
didn't know enough to contextualize it
so this is kind of a similar thing and
it kind of plays with that for a while
because
you know the kid you know he sees a few
things that
you're you know you're seeing them as
the viewer but you know you're seeing
them from his subjective point of view
so you're like is he really seeing
things
the way that they really are or is he
just like misunderstanding what's really
going on um and plus you know that he's
troubled you know he's been having
nightmares there's this one really great
like particularly uh particularly great
nightmare sequence where he's
kind of in he's hiding in the pantry
like watching his mom like cooking like
through the blinds
or through the slats in the door
and uh oh there's all these like big
sausages like up on the top shelf and
they kind of start to come to life and
sort of like come around like kind of
tentacles and he's just kind of like the
way he's looking at the side it's just
like really really cool [ __ ] like that
so like i said for a long time you're
not entirely sure if he's just being you
know like he doesn't understand like he
thinks they're cannibals because he
doesn't necessarily know what's going on
but i will say that
his interactions
with his dad
are like
super super creepy like i said randy
quaid is like so so good in this um he's
just kind of like just the way that he
says just this creepy stuff like he's
talking about um how how a room is dark
and he's like yeah the basement's dark
and this is you know whatever and then
he says something like
but you know what it's the most dark
place that you have to worry about and
then he like points to his head like in
here you know what i mean it's like that
kind of creepy [ __ ] and then he says
like weird [ __ ] to his son like he's
cooking him eggs and like you know more
meat like these big kidneys or liver or
whatever and he's cooking him breakfast
and the kid's sitting there watching him
and he's like oh you're watching me
that's good and he's like you know
um people are always watching you maybe
even when you're in the bathroom it's
like he's always like saying creepy [ __ ]
like that so it's like it's really
really it's like a really kind of
restrained performance it's like really
really unsettling and like i said it's
kind of a shame that he kind of went
looney tunes later on because
you know it's
it's over the top comedic as some of his
other roles were like i said i haven't
seen a ton of them but this one was
actually kind of like restrained but
also really good and you could and you
could kind of like feel like
that he was just kind of barely
you know he's just kind of like barely
keeping control over this like rage or
this whatever like psychopathy that was
going on like right underneath the
surface but he was trying to like
maintain this sense of normalcy and
stuff but yeah
so so there's that whole thing going on
so the kid like i said becomes convinced
that his parents are cannibals and at
school i guess that in the class he's
supposed to draw they're all supposed to
draw like their family like you know in
a little workbook or whatever
and uh so the drawing that he does is
basically like him like screaming and
then like the whole thing is covered
with red crayon and so he comes to the
attention of the school's social worker
he was played by sandy dennis
and uh interestingly in contrast to the
very
very 50s buttoned up you know bridge
playing uh you know everything is
perfect the hair is perfect you know all
that kind of stuff uh in in contrast to
that
sandy dennis's character the social
worker is almost kind of like a
proto-hippie in a way she kind of like
has all these kind of shawls and she's
kind of smoking in her office and she's
real disorganized and
chilling her hair is kind of messy and
[ __ ] like that and there's even a funny
line where they call michael where she
calls michael into the office and he
says something to her like you're not a
real grown-up so
you know what i mean because she's kind
of like kind of disheveled like i said a
little bit hippie-ish for like 1958.
now she becomes concerned about these
drawings and she can't really get any
information out of him like he doesn't
really want to tell anybody that he
thinks his parents are cannibals um so
he's very like reticent
and so the school like um you know the
social worker is actually starts to like
get worried about him and like she kind
of actually cares what's gonna happen to
him but she can't get any she can't get
a read on him she can't get any
information out he seems very
standoffish she seems very rude he won't
like really give her any information so
it's kind of hard for her to like
determine what's going on in his life
and uh so as it goes on
uh it kind of gets to a point where she
gets so worried that she basically like
comes with him back to the house because
you know he gets to a point where you
know it starts escalating and escalating
and he goes down to the cellar
and basically finds or it appears that
he finds like a human leg like hanging
from a meat hook like down in the cellar
now like i said you're not entirely sure
if he really sees this or not because
when
the social worker goes to the house with
them later it doesn't appear to be there
anymore however
uh while she's there she does actually
find a corpse and she ends up getting
killed so there's like this whole kind
of so like i said for for about three
quarters of the movie they leave it like
bob balaban he leaves it kind of like
ambiguous as to whether
this kid is just misinterpreting like
his parents weird-ass behavior um and
they're not really cannibals but you
know in the last part of it they make it
pretty definitive that yeah they are
cannibals although there's still like a
little bit of plausible deniability left
in there i guess a little bit so it does
have that going for it and at that point
like at the end of it basically it's
kind of like it's revealed that you know
the his parents actually do say to him
to his face you know yeah we're candle
cannibals you'll get used to it um you
know your mother did so that implying
that you know the mom didn't start out
as a cannibal but then like he kind of
like the husband sort of like
coerced her into it and then she she
says something like i learned to love it
or something like that so it's just kind
of this whole creepy thing but then it
ends up that um you know the kid like
trying to stabs his dad and then
you know the he goes to like kill the
kids and we can have another one and
then like you know but then like the mom
kind of defends the kid in the end but
in the end like the house kind of blows
up and they presumably both die and he's
said to live his grandparents but then
at the end you're not really sure if
because these are the dads his paternal
grandparents so you're not really sure
if they if
if if he learned the cannibalism from
them because like the very last thing is
the grandparents are like oh get in bed
little michael and blah blah blah and
then they bring him like for a midnight
snack they bring him this sandwich that
looks like household [ __ ] meat on it
and he's just like kind of looking at it
like that and it's just kind of but it's
just it's so this it's movie is like so
weird it's just like so like visually
it's really really cool and like really
really interesting like i said it has
kind of all these sort of lynchian
vibes too it has all these great like
tracking shots uh particularly this one
that a lot of people bring up when they
review the movie that kind of goes from
like all the way down in the cellar and
then goes all the way up like through a
floor great and then goes up through the
roof and all this other kind of stuff
which you know was kind of uh a pain in
the ass to pull off like especially in
like 1989 before they had you know cgi
or anything like that so uh but yeah
there's all kind of like really cool and
like i said the production design like
the particularly the interior design of
the house is just like really really
cool looking and like some of the shots
are just like gorgeous it's like looks
really cool and he uses kind of stuff
like there's slo-mo there's black and
white there's you know that kind of so
so it has kind of like a surrealist like
dream like sort of thing to it like i
said it's not
funny necessarily like not in a funny ha
ha kind of way it's kind of like a funny
disturbing like very very dry humor type
of way it's like really really hard to
describe if you haven't seen it um like
i said i know i understand why people
usually call it a horror comedy but
it's not like you know you know i mean
it's not like um you know tucker and
dale versus evil like which is obviously
a horror comedy and it's hilarious
this one is like a lot more the humor is
a lot weirder and a lot more subtle like
i said it's very
it does give me like a very society type
of vibe or like a twin peaks kind of
thing it is the very twin peaksy in
places um like i said i've heard some
people compare it to blue velvet which
blue velvet is a lot
you know more serious more more dramatic
and [ __ ] like that but this one has more
of like a john watersy type of vibe to
it too but like a dark john waters if i
i don't know it's like it's a weird like
combination but it's just like so
interesting that this movie
it's just like such a strange like relic
of the time and it's like i'm really
happy that i decided to watch it again
because i remembered i think i saw it on
cable probably back in like the early
90s or something
and i remembered liking it but i you
know and i remembered oh the kid like
thinks his parents are cannibals and
that's like pretty much all i remembered
about it and i said oh and they probably
then they really were cannibals and that
was like all i remembered about it and i
remembered it being kind of funny but
then like over the years since i hadn't
seen it and every now and then i'd see
that cover and i'd be like oh yeah that
was that was funny and stuff like that
but like when you watch it i guess
because like i said the cover makes it
look like a more straight like a horror
comedy but it's not like that it's like
really kind of
it's really kind of weird and surreal
and then in the last quarter of it it
goes pretty much straight horror movie
like you know what i mean like after the
um the social worker like goes to the
house and gets killed and [ __ ] like that
so it pretty much goes straight horror
movie at that point but i really really
liked
you know the way that everything was
kept
subjective like from michael's point of
view so for a long time you weren't
actually sure if the parents were
cannibals or if they were just like
[ __ ] weirdos and the kids didn't
really understand like what they were
looking at i will say too and you don't
necessarily have to read the movie like
this if you don't want to
but and i don't know if this was
intended i mean i'm sure it probably was
but there's totally i mean i caught a
subtext
of
of a thing where it's like the parents
aren't necessarily cannibals but he's
kind of like making there's like a
subtext about maybe
his family is abusive because there is
one interesting exchange between michael
and his little friend sheila and sheila
says something along the lines of oh you
know you think everyone else is like
your parents are weird or whatever but
it's like you think everyone else's
parents are so great you know i know you
know my mom is horrible and it's like i
i know this other guy like this friend
of my dad's and it's like he everybody
thinks he's this great guy but then like
he goes and steals cars and beats his
wife and stuff like that so i think that
he's kind of making a little bit of a
subtextual thing about
cannibalism as sort of like a stand-in
for
an abusive family whether it's
physically abusive or emotionally
abusive or you could even say it was
like a you know a parable for like
alcoholism or something like that
anything that's kind of like going on
anything dark that's going on beneath
the veneer of like this perfect family
you know that they're trying to portray
to the world so you could kind of see it
that way because i totally did read it
that way especially after that
after that one um after that one thing
because it's just kind of like because
the kid in it is so
i mean when you first meet him like i
said he has lines in it but not a lot
like most of the time he's just kind of
like standing around like looking
terrified or like looking weirded out
and but but he says a lot with his eyes
you know what i mean it's a very it
almost it's like a weird blank
expression but you can tell from his
expression that this in his body
language that he's just kind of like
terrified and he's not entirely sure
like what his dad in particular is going
to do like the mom doesn't come across
she still comes across as weird but she
comes across as
more
loving toward uh toward the kid whereas
the dad
just comes across as
just
bizarre like you know what i mean and
you can tell and it's i don't want to
say like resentment but it's just like
this really weird like vibe between the
two of them like the way he talks to him
and stuff but it's just kind of like so
so that was something that really like
struck a chord with me because i said oh
that seems like they're saying something
about like the dad being like abusive or
whatever but they're but he's using like
cannibalism as kind of like a stand-in
for that i guess but like i said you
don't have to read it like that you
could just totally read it as like a
weird-ass
weird-ass kind of funny surrealist movie
about you know a kid who finds out his
parents are cannibals i've seen this
compared to eating raul as well which uh
i could see that although i haven't seen
that move in a long time so i'm not
gonna get like too much into that
because i can't remember exactly what
happens in it uh you know surprisingly a
surprisingly
large number of comedies made of k about
cannibalism it's really interesting now
that i'm thinking about it but uh yeah i
was kind of think too that when i was
thinking about uh good kind of comedic
movies made about
cannibalism i was gonna say like oh
ravenous that was a good one too and i
feel like that's a one that doesn't
really get brought up a lot either
that's not
quite as funny but
and that's like a totally different vibe
to this one but it's a similar kind of
i don't know it's a similar kind of tone
in that it's funny but it's like a much
more dry humor which this one is too so
like i said if you like if you like twin
peaks if you like john waters uh if you
liked society that movie from 89
about the with the shunting
if if you like movies in that sort of
vibe and you're not expecting this to be
like laugh out loud funny because it's
not it's more like weird
and straight up horror toward the end
but if that sounds like something that
you would like then you should totally
check this one out because i feel like a
lot of people don't talk about this one
this is another one that i feel like
really needs a much bigger cult
following i know it has a small one but
i feel like it's not as large as it
probably should be
so this movie is actually i watched it
on 2b for free
i'm sure you can find it other streaming
services as well but like i said if you
don't have one and you you know and you
don't want to spend any money on it just
to see if you like it uh it's on tubey
for free and you can totally watch it
there but if you've seen it uh let me
know what you think about it in the
comments and uh that will do it for this
flickers of fear and i will see you guys
on the next one
bye